okay so it's been a it's been a couple
of months since we last talked what has
changed in your life oh uh
well for one hairs longer hair is longer
the beard's nice and long now as well
yeah
he's about to drop two weeks away um
a lot of stuff has happened everybody
wants to hit radio which is
insane i had my first show back at uh
like the olg play stage which is amazing
um honestly i can't complain i think
i've had it pretty good
uh comparatively so i know that uh you
and your fans they care everything there
is to care about you
so what has the reaction been to the
longer hair so far
it's been a little bit mixed uh mostly
positive
i hope um some people it's kind of it's
very polarizing some people love it
somebody will
look really bomb please change
how much how much time do you spend in
the comment section especially around a
time when you're releasing a new ep like
how much time
is it is it something you can't avoid or
do you find yourself like oh i have to
look i don't want to look i don't want
to look but i have to look
definitely when it's uh something
important one is just like a photo of me
on instagram i'm not gonna like i don't
care enough to
see if like somebody's calling me ugly
or whatever but if um if i'm
releasing something for example the ep
or a new song i'll definitely i'll
scour those comments looking for for
something negative i try not to and i
try not to let it affect me but
music is is something that i really
really care about so if people are
are saying something negative if there
is like a recurring theme then i feel
like i should know about it
uh the last time we talked i believe
that you were on your way to getting
your driver's license
and i find it wildly interesting that
you and i discussed your driving skills
because i know your sister said that you
were not the strongest driver
and now fast forward a couple of months
and you've done a
car video yeah it don't matter what she
says too because i'm
right here look at that you got it
yeah thank you it was a very scary test
um
and i'm obsessed with cars so that's
that's kind of something that i had
wanted to do for a really long time i
was i'm super super pumped that we got
to do it especially
now did you actually get to are you
driving in the video or is this like
movie magic where they hook you up to a
trailer
and you pretend to drive what's going on
there
well it's the real thing it's it's me
driving um
it was like a back
alley like some like just random
deserted street in toronto we didn't
have permits i don't know if i should
say that but we didn't have permits so
we had to do it like quickly we did like
two takes then we were out of there
so but it is you driving though it is
yeah
okay and whose car was that and were you
nervous at all
that was a rental car we got from like a
just somebody that universally uses a
lot uh for
getting like cool older cars uh
i was so nervous because driving a car
from
the 80s is a lot different than
a car from the 2010s um
like every time you like put it in a
different gear it would like like
move up which is kind of a weird
sensation
i thought i broke it multiple times but
you know it's just old
uh well how what did you feel about the
cartoon version of you and had you
seen it like ahead of time or was it all
a big surprise up to you
no i i saw it ahead of time i was super
super excited about it um
we like super meticulously went over
like the type of animation we wanted to
look like
whether it was gonna be like anime ask
or more realistic
we kind of settled for somewhere in
between um
so it's still like you know animated
it's like this
out of the box guy who's like drifting
all over the place
um but it still kind of looks like me
which i think is cool
uh one of the things i because i've
known you for a long time and we've
talked
multiple times um i've never heard you
swearing a song before and you sort of
dip your toe
a little bit into profanity in this
track was that a debate or did that come
naturally were there discussions how did
that happen
uh it kind of like went unsaid until i
was recording it like i kind of just
like didn't mention it and then i got in
the booth and i was like
okay like you're going for it but yeah i
kind of just went like
and then i now does that change things
like
i don't know explain to me like does
that change the sort of rating you get
on streams or downloads do they have to
put an explicit thing beside it
does this now put you into a different
category
it does traditionally negatively affect
the uh performance of the song just
because it's
a now explicit song um but i mean
it seems to be doing pretty well we have
a clean version as well as well
so i don't think it was uh
it was such a big deal as it was kind of
made out to be beforehand but
um i don't know if people seem to like
it when i started at the show people
were ah
okay now executives aside in the record
business aside because really
let's just leave them over there but was
there anybody in your
life in your family who was like oh so
we're doing that now in songs are we
yeah my my mom um
she we have a video actually of her
hearing it for the first time like the
mix and she went
i don't know i think we posted it right
no we
will be a little ep um dog experience
but um yeah my mom kind of freaked out
everybody else was kind of like
chill with it um one thing i love about
you is that they always say you know
artists have to sort of grow with their
audience but knowing your career as well
as i do
it's it's not so much growing but it is
it's a steady evolution that you've had
um especially in the in the last sort of
year and a half
um how do you see it how do you sort of
look at your
next steps and getting to the next level
as you mature
as a guy right um well i mean
it's hard to predict something like that
and that's kind of the whole basis of
the eep
um you know when i dropped teenage fever
i kind of thought that that was just me
that was me forever i was done
developing those who i am
at the ripe age of 16 years old
now in hindsight is really dumb i
i don't know why i thought that but i
didn't um so
you know i've kind of just learned to to
embrace change um
i know as a person that i'll keep
changing until the day i die
um and you know that's something that
i'm cool with it's not as scary as it
used to be i used to be
very scared of getting older um but you
know now
i just kind of embrace it do you know
are you planning your next steps right
now
do you know sort of the next the next
person you
you want to be for sure um i mean
i guess the only thing that i've really
planned um
is just to try and get more real and
more me
my music i want to start writing uh a
lot more
um and i actually wrote this song
super super personal just something that
i would not have been able to do
a year ago i wrote it the other day um
so that was kind of like a pretty big
step for me
uh as for like music wise we have like
kind of the next like six months or so
planned out we have some some cool
things up our sleeve so that'll be cool
when you do start writing and you start
getting personal there's a vulnerability
that comes with that how are you with
being a little bit more vulnerable
for me it's kind of like it's either
nothing or it's all of it um i kind of
like either i make like a like a more
shallow
track uh it's kind of just like fun and
upbeat or i just kind of pour
everything that i have into the song and
that was the case for this one
um it is it was about something that
happened in my life that uh
really affected me so i hope that i can
share that soon but
it was it's definitely all or nothing
for me i spent a little bit of time in
the comment section and the one thing
that comes up more than anything else is
who is everybody wants you about
[Music]
well i privacy reasons we're gonna
withhold names but
um everybody wants you is about
those girls that in my town that i've
known for all my life that just
actually run the place um you know
they change they're they're everywhere
you go really and that's what i think
the beauty of the song is it's so
applicable to wherever you live
uh like i've been to a lot of schools
and there's always
like three or four girls that just
absolutely run the school everybody
loves them
or hates them but everybody knows them
they're like the popular girls
and these and these girls affected you
how oh man
do we have a history um
well i've been when i was younger more
foolish
i fell into their trap um and you know
i fell for one of these girls and that
was a bad time for me
um got a lot of songs out of it which
was good but
uh that was a tough time for sure uh
they just kind of like
signs of these kind of girls are like um
like no commitment
type deal um and
like i don't know just like getting let
on
how does it feel when you go to sit down
and you want to you want to do a song
about this
but you want it to be meaningful and you
you want it to be your art and you want
it to be true
but also there's a balance of i don't
want it to be about revenge
so talk to me about that line
for sure that's a super super important
line to kind of dance around
and that came to play a lot and waste my
time which was on my last ep
and then once you as well you have to
tone back the like the whatever feelings
you might have and
and make sure that it's still like a fun
loving song because like
whatever thoughts or or feelings may
have towards this person you can't
put it all out there because um to an
extent
those negative feelings are probably um
just a little angry and you don't want
that and
hold on it's just very aggressive
you have to kind of like it's
it's it's a fine line you have to have
lines like
i wish that you would look at me the way
that uh
and i wish that you would look at me the
way you look at natural reflect
um and then you have to have lines like
uh now everybody's watching you and i
can tell you're loving the attention so
the latter would be the more aggressive
line
and then the former is like that but i
wish you would look at me
right now talk me through this mtv
nickelodeon deal that you have
this is huge yeah so
basically um on the viacom side that's
like a consumer product deal so we're
going to be
making a ton of cool stuff which i'm
very excited about like
literally everything t-shirts hats
necklaces
which i've wanted to do literally since
i started music
i've always wanted to like make my own
for example i wear this chain every day
i want to make one of these bad boys i
want to make rings that are my own i
just want
i just want to have creative control
over
everything and just make dope stuff so
that's kind of like the
the consumer product side of it and then
i guess the
the mtv nickelodeon side is kind of like
um
it's kind of like a development type
deal um
working a lot with them and uh they're
going to be
you know giving feedback on on me and
and
uh yeah it's it's kind of like a little
bit of uh give-and-take
are you gonna do more acting yeah so
that's part of it um
i'm not the biggest actor like i'm not
i
but i'm super excited to be able to play
some cool roles
uh listen man it is always so incredible
to
hang with you and again i know i said
this the last time but hopefully
the next time we do this we are able to
hang out in the same room
uh congratulations on everything and
especially congratulations on getting
your license man
you